[موسيقى]
للامطار مواسم شتويه وصيفيه وخريفيه
الشتويه تبدا مع دخول موسم سهيل في اواخر
اغسطس لا دخل سهيل لا تامن
والصيفيه تبدا مع دخول موسم العقارب في
شهر مارس لادخلت العقارب ترى الخير قارب
وتنتهي مع دخول موسم اتوابع في شهر يونيو
اتويبع راعي بروج ومخايل ومذكر وادي ينبت
ويبع سايل ومع نهايه الامطار الصيفيه تبدا
الامطار الخريفيه على جنوب السعوديه
واليمن وسلطنه عمان وسميت بالخريفيه لانها
تتزامن مع موسم خراف الثمار فالسماء تمطر
عندهم وحنا بعز القير ولسانه حالهم يقول
ولنا مطر المقيض بشهر اب وتموز وانتم
مجذبون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واطول موسم امطار بالعالم يكون على الدول
العربيه يمتى تقريبا لتسعه شهور لكنه شحيح
المطر وقبل الاف السنين كانت المده اقصر
سته شهور تقريبا لكن مطرها اغزر واثرها
اوضح على الارض بالانبات يفنى العباد ولا
تفنى صنائعهم فاختر لنفسك ما يحلو به
الاثر
[موسيقى]